now senator elizabeth warren lashing out
at the world's richest man a lot smarter
than her elon musk after he called her
quote senator karen during a twitter
rift over tax policy it started after
musk was name time magazine's person of
the year one of the most interesting
people in the country right now in my
view to which far left senator
warren tweeted quote let's change the
rig tax code so the person of the year
will actually pay taxes and stop free
loading off everyone else to which musk
responded
you remind me of when i was a kid and my
friend's angry mom would just randomly
yell at everyone for no reason please
don't call the manager on me senator
karen and adding quote if you open your
eyes for two seconds you would realize
that i will pay more taxes than any
american in history this year
checkmate elon musk now after that
response warren while couldn't let it go
appearing on msdnc's joy read show to
lash out even more take a look
the world's richest freeloader evidently
has a very thin skin they head off into
outer space and declare how they did
this all on their own when they were
subsidized by the federal government and
subsidized by every waitress and by
every public school teacher who paid
their taxes
this is wrong and elon musk needs to eat
a big dish of that
now responds musk wrote lack of joy uh
joy reid lack of joy reid is a lobbyist
for senator karen all right here with
reaction author of now a new york times
best seller for such a time for such a
time as this outnumbered co-host kaylee
mcinerney along with outkick founder
clay travis uh i find this interesting
you know i i watched the series the men
that built america it's about you know
the fords the rockefellers the carnegies
et cetera
and
all of them very interesting and i kind
of look at elon musk
kaylee as a modern day version of that
and i would think that someone like
elizabeth warren a new green deal you
know climate cultist
would like the fact that he's thinking
out of the box getting new technology
i'm fascinated by what he does and and
want to see him be successful
no doubt i mean elon musk is an american
success story he came to this country uh
went to college took out a hundred
thousand dollars in student loans worked
two jobs to try and pay it off and now
is a billionaire paying more taxes as he
noted than anyone in in history in uh in
this year alone he noted so look i i
think when you look at wokism which is a
very powerful drug this is a man who
said i'm not going to be a billionaire
elite i'm not going to just say what is
woke say what is liberal say what is
expected of me
i'm going to just be me and he's doing
just that cutting through the noise
holding a powerful senator accountable
he's done the same with bernie sanders i
am so impressed by him and sean when you
said he's one of the most interesting
people in america i couldn't agree more
elon musk pretty much deserves that
title at this point you know i mean he's
a fascinating guy clay i i watch at what
he does i'm amazed by it
um
right now the lifeblood of the world's
economy is oil gas and coal
uh if there's new cheaper energy
technology that comes along and he helps
develop it
all power to him um he's advancing the
human condition um he's gone he's gone
far already i'm i'm very interested to
see what he does next
look sean if he's a freeloader we need a
lot more freeloaders because here's what
he's done first of all he immigrated
from south africa as kaylee said came to
school here made initially money with
paypal and then decided you know what i
think i can build rockets better than
nasa and he did it and then he also
thought hey you know what this
combustion engine and our overall
reliance on oil doesn't make a lot of
sense i would like to develop a new car
founded on electricity to help to create
some energy independence and he did it
and in the process he's become the
richest man in the world and as he right
rightfully tweeted he's about to pay
more tax than anyone has ever paid in
the history of the united states of
america elon musk represents everything
that america should be about he's
dynamic he's risk-taking he's forwarding
one of the things is it hamstrung by
government i love him and i i'm i'm
fascinated by the guy and by the way he
didn't lie about his nationality to get
ahead in her in his career
that's a plus in my book
and
he she stole her you know the pow wow
chow book elizabeth warren the irony
there is joy reid defended uh elizabeth
warren by saying that that elon musk was
appropriating do you see this the word
karen in his insult with senator karen
and she did that to defend uh elizabeth
warren who lied about being a native
american so she could get a law
professor job and then stole a recipe
for a native american cookbook called
pow wow
this is an unbelievable story i forgot
kayla you get the last word tonight and
congrats on being uh new york times
bestseller
thank you and you are instrumental in
helping to push for such time as this so
thank you sean i would just say this we
need more non-politicians in the swamp i
was in the swamp i happen to work for a
non-politician president donald j trump
the greatest uh president of our time we
need more people like elon musk getting
in the game and he might just be doing
that he's tweeting about buildback
better
he's very good at branding lack of joy
reid as you noted so hey elon musk you
may have a political future we we need
more people like you entrepreneurs and
the swamp it takes a lot of courage to
go there and leave what's comfortable
and he may be doing that i i don't think
elizabeth warren understands what risk
it takes to build a business there's a
lot of risk
a lot of people that try fail and those
that are successful ought to be
celebrated and guess what that money's
not hers and the taxes that he's paying
is enormous and if he did it in another
country it'd save a lot more money we
should be glad we have him here thank
you both hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else